well I want to see what your reaction is
right here let's get the camera on that
no sit down you're working for us oh
very cute yeah do you do this your
employees maybe you aren't cut from the
same cloth he would be your supervisor
in a coal mine yes sorry dude that was
rude
no I'll never do that today again I'll
do it again but not today again that's a
little too much I have a beautiful guest
here I apologize but can I just finish
my [ __ ] point the point man is is
that because apparently I go to this
Korean spa Yun die hard more mad dog you
the whole time and then the owner of it
have your met him he's gonna dig this
big he's Korean Idol operation he knew
what he does he'll walk into the steam
room and everyone knows him cuz he owns
it yeah and you'll put his hands behind
his head like this and stand in the
steam room like this with his long dick
right and everyone are like what a Power
Move it's a Power Move dude and you can
play ping pong no I've never done the
massage but the people who play ping
pong the early JIT would you they come
with their like Olympic gear with their
bags yes that's what we don't go there
because we went there one yeah we try to
play things we try to play there but
everyone was so good and we're like
hitting the ceiling the balls are flying
all over the [ __ ] place and they kept
looking at us like [ __ ] this place yeah
[ __ ] it but the steam room is hot as
[ __ ] right Roy
yes yeah when you go there I haven't
been in a while but when I used to go
there like when we ran the Lion Hotel I
used to go to like unwind and [ __ ] yeah
yeah I want to go there with you do like
the Conan Stevie in episode
what would you we I mean do you get
full-blown naked like I stopped that a
while ago I I can't do it anymore man I
just go directly from the front desk
through the sauna up to upstairs and get
the massage you won't you won't go in
you won't get naked and go in the steam
room I did for a long time I just I
reached the point where I was done with
it how do you get over it's my quota I
didn't know I had a quota and then I
reached that quota
yeah yeah because I but I you know I'm
driving home that day hello we're gonna
take a quick break to share this awesome
sponsor with you
quick quick quick you put it in your
mouth quick quick quick